along with some new projects I was also
offered a 15 salary hike on my current
job my simply learned data engineering
certification was recognized by my
current employer and gave me tremendous
opportunities to grow
hi my name is Christian Lopez and I'm
currently working at Credit One Bank as
a data scientist I live in Las Vegas
Nevada with my family
although I hold the cognitive
Neuroscience degree I've always had a
passion for data engineering
after graduating I joined a financial
institution as a data analyst now I've
been working as a data scientist for
over a year and a half
although I had already taken data
science and data engineering courses in
the past I knew that simply Learners
comprehensive program would offer the
projects that I needed in order to
succeed I knew that in order to grow in
my current position I needed to take on
data engineering projects and simple
Learners program was a way to do it I
came across a postgraduate program in
data engineering from Simply learn in
conjunction with Purdue University after
looking at the curriculum I knew it was
the right program for me I'm so happy I
made this decision
along with some new projects I was also
offered a 15 salary hike on my current
job my simply learned data engineering
certification was recognized by my
current employer and gave me tremendous
opportunities to grow
overall it was such a tremendous
experience the program and the
instructors were top-notch and they were
always available to answer any of the
questions that I had during the duration
of the program I am so happy I made this
decision to take this course and I would
really recommend it to anyone trying to
advance in their careers
during my free time I really like to
spend time with family and friends walk
my dog and Play Soccer outside
[Music]